hey guys pete here fargo's season 4
episode 9 takes a turn
overall i think it was a pretty good
thing it's an aussie in episode although
rabbi and satchel don't actually
leave kansas they do leave kansas city
and that sets things up for an episode
that's packed with interesting
characters
a lot of interesting little details and
the chance to focus on a self-contained
story with two of the most interesting
characters in this season
over the last 24 hours as i've been
thinking about it
i'm not sure what it says about the big
picture of what's going on and we can
talk about that later
but i did think it was the strongest
episode of the season
and i had a lot of fun looking into all
the different details that were packed
away
so this is your spoiler warning of
course this is going to talk about
everything that happened in episode 9.
if you haven't watched it if you're not
caught up go and do that
hit the subscribe button on your way out
then come back and watch the recap and
review and join the conversation in the
comments
with that out of the way let's get to it
so episode 9 starts off in color and we
see
what's left of the house after it's been
destroyed
there's a copy of the history of true
crime in the midwest
which is a book that we first heard
about in season two
and the camera focuses in on a page that
says chapter seven liberal kansas 1950
who shot willie booper when you read the
text you can see that this is a
description of what's going to happen at
the end of the episode
after that it shifts to black and white
and we see that omi's on the road
looking for rabbi
he has a guy named aldo who works for
the fada family in the trunk
and he's told him that constant came
looking for guns that he's out trying to
kill a swede or an
irishman they pull into a gas station on
the side of the road that's basically in
the middle of nowhere
omi asked the attendant if he's seen
constant calamita pass through he hasn't
seen the man
but he tells him that he probably thinks
he'll stop there if he's going that way
because it's the only station around
omi makes a deal with the guy telling
him he'll paint the building if he can
hide his car out back and wait he has
aldo help him and eventually they go
inside to have a coke and take a break
aldo tries to bond with him a little bit
saying they have something in common
they both are on the bottom of the
ladder
he uses this story of the king of the
turtles who stacks himself on top of his
underling so that he can see
far and wide at the same time constant
pulls up
aldo tries to take off omi shoots him
and then we go back in time one day and
catch up with rabbi and satchel
we see that they're on the same road
they pass by the same plaque about the
discoverer of pluto that we saw omi
standing by before
they make it to a place called liberal
kansas which we learn is the pancake hub
of the universe from the sign
and they pull up at the barton arms
boarding house with the intention of
taking a couple of days to figure out
where they're gonna go
the barton arms is an interesting name
it definitely makes you think about the
movie barton fink
which also took place in a boarding
house hotel kind of thing
something i learned when i looked this
up though was that it's actually the
name of an apartment building
in miller's crossing and they used it
there as a nod to
barton fink which they wrote while
taking a break on writing miller's
crossing
another connection with barton is the
author of the book the history of true
crime in the midwest
his name was barton brixby there's
another interesting plaque here
this time the marker for the melon
mounds this is about the story of the
melon family
who had a propensity for taking
travelers in and then killing them with
a hammer
and then burying them near the barton
arms the bodies were
found but the melons escaped and no one
knows what happened to them
after reading this rabbi tells satchel
to sleep with one eye open
and that's something that donatella fada
told zero before
sending him to live with the cannons
when they go inside things continue to
get quirkier the woman behind the
counter asks them a series of questions
in an effort to figure out where to put
them in that process we see these photos
of women
on the back wall we'll learn that those
are sisters who can't get along so they
split the building in half
and if we're thinking about the wizard
of oz it has a feeling
of the wicked witch of the east and the
wicked witch of the west
we also learned that even though the
woman who's working behind the counter
is african-american
that the sisters don't like black people
and she warns satchel to avoid them
on the way to their room they pass by
another where there's a man with
bandages
hooked up to some machines with a
younger guy taking care of him and we'll
see these two
later once they get settled in rabbi
explains he's got a mission here in town
he leaves him with his knife and he
tells him some instructions and it
reinforces that idea of
rabbi doing his best to look out for
satchel in the midst of this crazy
situation that they've found themselves
in
when he makes it to town rabbi realizes
the place he stashed his money years ago
is no longer there and when he goes
inside he realizes the wall that it was
hidden behind
is missing the new owner has what's
basically a
furniture appliance store he explains
that him and his brother bought the
place at
auction the whole situation throws rabbi
for a loop so he takes off to think
about what his next step is
back at the room satchel hears a noise
inside the wardrobe and he finds a dog
named rabbit which looks a lot like toto
from the wizard of oz
he winds up chasing her downstairs and
meets a couple of the guys who are
staying in the house
he meets a talkative guy named hunk
who's really into dale carnegie's
how to win friends and influence people
and then a younger guy
named hickory who's headed for texas to
become an oilman
rabbi returns he explains that he ran
into a setback
he says only a fool thinks the world is
going to stay exactly as it was
and then it's time for dinner where we
see the whole cast of characters who
stay inside the barton arms
the sisters are old they are eccentric
one of them doesn't want satchel sitting
at the dinner table but the other one
allows him to do so just so she can go
against whatever her sister wants
i'll talk a little bit more about the
individual characters here later but
what i think is most important about
this dinner conversation
is this idea about the story of
goldilocks hunk says it's the classic
example of an outsider in search of
himself and he talks about how the story
doesn't really have an ending the bears
get justice
they get rid of the intruder but
goldilocks herself is left back out in
the cold
she doesn't fit anywhere and that does
resemble the situation that satchel is
going to find himself
in the next day starts off with the
billboard across the street
we've seen that it says the future is
and we don't know where that's going
rabbi pulls over to ask the guy saying
that
making people live with uncertainty it
ain't right but the guy who's hanging it
he's more concerned with himself and
making this job last because he's soon
going to be unemployed
they go back to the store where a rabbi
is going to try to get his money back
he leaves satchel in the car with the
dog and that leads to a tense situation
when a police officer sees him and comes
up to the car
inside the brothers admit that they did
find the money but they spent most of it
so rabbi gets what they have left and
there's a tense moment where you think
that he might kill one of them
and that something might really go wrong
with this cop and satchel
but both situations end up diffused and
i think this is what works really best
about this format where we're only
following these two characters
since we have this idea in the back of
our mind that this is a young mike
milligan
the episode really has this idea that
rabbi could die at any second hanging
over it
back at their room rabbi tells them
they're going to leave and he doesn't
want to bring rabbit
this brings up the idea that satchel sad
because he wanted just one thing for
his birthday which is today this is the
first that rabbi heard of that so he
goes downstairs trying to find something
to give him like a cupcake or a candy
bar
turns out the sisters don't believe in
sugar so the woman at the counter sends
him down to the filling station
and everything comes together where we
realize that that's probably where omi
and kalamita were when we last saw them
on his way rabbi sees the now completed
billboard and it says the future is now
he's not impressed so he talks to the
guy again who says
i don't know maybe it's about the
unreliability of time or maybe it's a
seize the day type message
either way the future that this guy was
worried about has arrived he is now
unemployed and i did like this quite a
bit rabbi gets to the service station we
see that it is the same one
we see that there are storm clouds
gathering we see the attendant's feet
sticking outside of the door
his striped socks seem like a reference
to the wicked witch although he's not
wearing ruby slippers
after seeing the body rabbi approaches
with caution through the window he sees
omi on the ground shot with constant
standing over him
he makes a noise which constant hears
that sends him outside
after him after taking a couple shots
rabbi gets hit in the shoulder
as he's trying to reach safety behind
his car as
constance readying himself to finish him
off omi comes with one shot left and
shoots
constant and then without bullets he's
dispatched rabbi
is having trouble because he's been shot
he can't actually raise his gun up
he starts to get it together but the
wind's so bad that a piece of wood flies
through the air and hits him
and as it looks like constant's gonna
finish him off the tornado arrives it
sweeps him up
the station starts breaking apart
rabbi's car is
gone rabbi realizes he's not gonna get
away
so there's this great shot of him where
he just sort of raises his arms up
and he goes up into the sky back at the
room satchel had fallen asleep he wakes
up
doesn't know what's going on and he
walks through the door of the bedroom
where we see the black and white
disappear
and the color come back into the scene
he goes next door we saw the guy that
was wrapped in bandages
and this time he talks to him and he has
a healthy fear of this situation
i read somewhere that what he's saying
comes from the book of revelations
and now that we can see his face we see
that this is actually the same actor
ira amex who played rabbi's father the
leader of the irish gang
he freaks satchel out he goes back to
the room barricades himself in and then
falls asleep for the night
the next morning he wakes up he's had it
reinforced to him several times that if
he doesn't see rabbi
that means he's dead or in jail although
it's interesting that this is the one
time he left and he didn't actually say
that to him
but he knows that he has to leave and he
does he stops to look at the billboard
the future is now and i guess in a way
it is for him the character has
transformed into something new
and the episode ends there so like i was
saying i do think this is the best
episode that doesn't mean that i don't
have a ton of questions about what
actually happened
and i spent a lot of time looking at
these different details and trying to
tie it all together
coming to the conclusion that i don't
really know there's a lot here that's
still sort of open-ended
when i watched it the first time the one
problem i had was at the end
i was so invested in this journey it
felt so tight like a self-contained
story
so i had the expectation that there
would be a definitive answer
of course i was thinking this was going
to be that we're going to see that
satchel becomes mike milligan
and as i watched him walk down the road
i thought this isn't a great ending for
this character he's just a kid
but i realized that it's actually the
ending of rabbi's story
of course we lose other characters we
lose omi and we lose constant but it
really is the end of rabbi's story
it's up for debate whether you like the
idea of the tornado or not there had
been some foreshadowing that something
like this was coming
dr senator mentioned the tornado in the
beginning of the very first episode we
saw a janitor at ethelrita school
cleaning some graffiti of a tornado off
the wall so generally speaking i'm all
right with it
as far as the big picture and about
satchel's story i don't think we've seen
the end of it yet
it's not clear how this is going to
affect the main story because we don't
know what's going to happen with him
technically if you think about it he's a
kid so the most likely thing that would
happen to him is he would try to make it
home to his parent
if we don't think he's going to die if
we think he's going to be mike milligan
then somehow he's going to survive
and while we see he's in a dangerous
situation we have to take into
consideration that rabbi had been
preparing him the best that he could
the big questions of things i can't
answer are things like where did the dog
come from
what is that supposed to mean why was
the page from the book
who shot willie booper in the aftermath
of the tornado that led to the story
that it's describing
is that a hint at something more or is
it just a clever device to give us some
exposition it says that five bodies were
recovered
at least four died of gunshot wounds
which would be constant aldo
omi and the attendant and then rabbi had
been shot but maybe he didn't die from
that
maybe he died from the tornado itself
same thing with the guy next door
using the same actor that played rabbi's
dad is this just a reference to the
curse that he was talking about
in his last minutes or is that supposed
to be a hint at something more
also we have all these strange
characters staying in this boarding
house are they just there to be
interesting characters or are we
supposed to read more into that
i mean there's a lot of wizard of oz
references i think you could assign the
roles of the characters that dorothy
meets in the wizard of oz to these guys
but i mean we see this really weird
pastor who's traveling with his mother
that everyone thought was his wife
they're folding up a flag get this old
guy who's a veteran
he's with what he refers to as his niece
but she doesn't talk to him that way
there's a lot of weird stuff going on
it's also interesting that they used
that quote from bertram russell in the
very beginning
this is not something they usually do
what we saw on screen was that
life is nothing but a competition to be
the criminal rather than the victim
and if you read this in the context of
the letter that he wrote to his lover
that it's taken from
there's another line there that says
people seem good while they're oppressed
but then they only wish to become
oppressors in their turn
so all of that makes sense for the
overarching themes of the season but i'm
not really sure how that ties into the
episode we just watched so it will be
interesting to see how that all ties
together
there's two episodes to go we got a lot
of stuff going on
i think this was a strong setup for the
ending so i hope they can pull it all
off
as mentioned i'm interested to hear what
you guys think so tell me in the
comments
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon